Extremities is back and better than ever,
but it’s going to be different.
Much has changed since the last season of
the Extremities podcast.
Travel screeched to a halt, and with this
standstill went my ability to visit, document,
and share the stories of far-away places.
Yet, through all the changes and tumult brought
on by the last 18 months, some things stayed
quite the same—principally, telling stories
of the world’s most remote settlements remained
a core interest of mine.
And so, while serving the same purpose—to
access and explain the isolated and difficult-to-comprehend
corners of the globe—Extremities is returning,
but in a new form… and this time you’re
going to need a screen.
Extremities is relaunching as a standalone
YouTube channel.
For those of you curious as to how a civil
war influences one of the most biodiverse
islands on the planet, how French culture
perpetuates in the subantarctic, or why centuries-old
Atlantic island communities have been all-but-abandoned
over the course of just a few decades, come
on over to the Extremities channel right now
and give it a watch.
The first two videos are up now; the third
will go up in a week, or it’s on Nebula
now; and then more will go out every third
Wednesday after that.
Each video features interviews with locals
and experts alike—taking you to the place,
introducing you to its people, and telling
its story.
Ad-free episodes along with extended cuts
of interviews will also be available for Nebula
subscribers.
So, head to this link, clickable at the top
of the description, to watch and subscribe
to Wendover Productions’ newest channel.